[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLIN QUINN: Thanks, David.
Thank you.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Thank
you so much for coming.
COLIN QUINN: Sure.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So what do
we do about this free speech
thing?
COLIN QUINN: Well,
it's too late.
It's too late to stop it now.
People want to
speak, unfortunately.
Yeah, I mean, look,
it's like anything else.
Everything starts
out as a great idea,
and then just dwindles
down to destroyed by us.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: OK.
Well, congratulations
on your show.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Great
reviews all the way around.
It's been extended
through March.
And it even had great reviews
in both "The New York Times"
and "The National Review."
COLIN QUINN: Yes, I know.
I was--
DAVID WINDMUELLER: I mean,
mission accomplished.
What did you-- were you
surprised by this feedback?
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
I mean, I've gotten a
lot of weird reviews
anyway in my career.
So it's like at a
certain point, you just
become numb to any abuse of it.
So I was surprised,
and happily surprised,
that I was getting good reviews.
But I mean, yeah, obviously,
I mean, getting reviews,
it's supposed--
I mean, that's how I am anyway.
I'm not really left or right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
And every single one of the
reviewers got something out.
It was like a "Rashomon" thing.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Where
they were each hearing,
yeah, Colin's telling
it like it is.
And each side heard
their own thing.
COLIN QUINN: That's
the weird thing.
It's like after the
show, the whole show's
about how everybody is just--
this is just ridiculous,
and how we're all not that
bright yet as far as human
nature.
And then people come up to
me at the show going, yeah,
they start yelling
about the same things
that I'm complaining about.
My show is me
complaining that people
have the right to complain
on social media, basically.
I mean, if you really look
at it past the opening level,
it's just me being a
hypocrite and saying, nobody
should be allowed to say all
these things except for me.
But I'm trying to hide it.
But they're just-- but it's like
everything just goes right back
into--
everybody is in this-- it's
so locked in right now.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: It's like mass
brainwashing, mass hysteria.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: You did a lot
of research for both this show,
for your constitutional show.
Did you find anything
surprising like in the founding
of the country or the
discourse in that process?
COLIN QUINN: Yeah, just that it
never really took off the way--
it was never--
it's just been a
fight the whole way.
Like in the constitution
show, I would
say it was fine when nobody knew
what anybody else was doing.
But since social
media, everybody
knows exactly how
everybody else is.
So you can't just be like,
ah, I never see them anyway.
You see everybody, each
other's face all day.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
That's interesting,
because are we like now breeding
these internet savvy personas
to excel, as opposed
to like the policy
wonks that we've created
like in high school elections
that we hated them before.
Is this what we
are creating now?
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
I wonder, because like I'll just
take comedians, for example.
A lot of comedians suddenly
became very serious people.
And so I always say
everybody is trying
to be funny on social
media except comedians.
But it's like suddenly
people-- this other side.
It's almost like a--
remember Beyonce had like
that side personality.
I forget the name.
And if I knew the name, you
all would be creeped out.
AUDIENCE: Sasha Fierce.
COLIN QUINN: Sasha Fierce.
Thank you.
And I shouldn't
have even been that
quick to know what you were
talking about, but I did.
But I'm just saying I feel like
online people do have this side
personality now, where
people I know-- and I'm like,
just online they're a
different person than they
are in real life.
That's the other weird thing.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: You had
a side personality before.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, online.
Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: No,
no, no, not online.
In your book you
talk about Colim.
COLIN QUINN: That's quite a
jump, but all right, yeah.
Back when I used to
drink in my early 20's.
But I used to pretend to be--
I was trying to pick
up girls, and I would
pretend I had an Irish accent.
I mean, I would just put on
this Northern Irish accent.
It's not as lame as it sounds.
It was a specific Belfast--
it wasn't like a
Lucky Charms guy.
This was like a serious--
I was doing serious
character work.
And I would just sit
at the bar by myself,
because nobody wanted to
hang out with me anyway,
because I was like the
real typical idiot drunk.
And I'd just be like, (IRISH
ACCENT) hey, how you doing?
And I'd been talking to
like all these people.
And I'd say my name was Colim.
And I would hint around
that I was from Belfast,
and I had to leave under murky
circumstances because of an IRA
thing.
It ended with-- a lot of times,
it ended in a lot of violence,
where I caught a
lot of beatings.
I'll be honest.
But that was my plan.
And it seemed like--
it worked for a while.
It would work for
like a half hour.
And then something would
happen where I'd be exposed.
Or the girl would just
be like, you just said--
now you said you're from
Brooklyn, or something.
I'd be like, ah, you know?
And it was just
never really panned
out the way I had it
planned in my head.
Look, I'm not proud of it.
I'm just saying it was an idea.
You're in your early 20's.
You want to meet women or men.
And you have ideas.
That was my idea.
I committed to it.
And I would just lock in.
It's the mind like
after a couple of beers.
I was like, I'm Colim now.
And I'd walk in.
I had like a green corduroy
jacket with patches
and like an Irish sweater.
If you saw me at that time--
I know now it looks like
it wouldn't-- at that time,
it could have worked on you.
You'd be surprised.
Smoking, you know?
The bar, tortured.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So
getting back to your show.
COLIN QUINN: Yes.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
COLIN QUINN: But
I forgot to say,
I had read this
one big book called
"Trinity" about the Irish.
So I stole the name.
I stole every aspect of
the guy's personality,
except that was
set in the 1800s,
and mine was in the 1970s.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
COLIN QUINN: So everything else
was just right from that book.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Leon Uris.
COLIN QUINN: So anybody
who read the book--
yeah, Leon Uris.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: And it
was a popular book,
so I probably got called out
a few times on that one, too.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
Oh, you're a reader.
COLIN QUINN: I love to read.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And so
like Joyce, another Irish.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Anything
else that has really
impressed you greatly.
COLIN QUINN: I mean, not lately.
But I mean, my favorite
book of all time
is called "Confederacy
of Dunces,"
which is like to me the
funniest book ever written.
And I still read
it all the time.
And I'm obsessed with
it my whole life.
But I mean, yeah,
I love to read.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: You said
it was a test for dating.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
I actually used it.
I used to buy it for whatever
girlfriend I was dating.
I'm not coming
across good in this.
I get it.
You're like, this
guy's a monster.
Fraudulent accents.
Testing people with books.
Hey, I never said
I was a great guy.
I'm a comedian.
Nice is not funny.
And yeah, so I would give
the book to whatever girl
I was dating.
And I'd say, hey,
it's a great book.
And if she liked it, then
I felt like we connected.
And if she didn't like
it, I was like, ah, man,
this is going to-- but girls
gave me books to test, too.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
Any you remember?
COLIN QUINN: "Frankenstein,"
which I'd never read before,
and I was like, wow, it
was really-- it's deep.
It's so much deeper.
And speaking of today, there's
something about "Frankenstein."
I've been thinking about
"Frankenstein" lately,
which is like the
thing on social media
is people we do love--
I love it, too-- to go after
somebody that you don't like,
like the instinct of vigilante.
Just get them.
Get them.
It's such a human nature thing.
It's just crazy.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And we've
made it a lot more efficient
now.
COLIN QUINN: And we've made
it a lot more efficient.
Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
It's very efficient.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: Because
Frankenstein was a good guy.
When you read the
book, you're like, oh,
Frankenstein was a good--
the monster was a good guy,
and the doctor was a good guy.
It just was he had
like a bad spin.
They just caught--
you know what I mean?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Bad PR.
COLIN QUINN: It's almost, yeah.
It almost was like an early
social media commentary.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Mmm.
Next project.
COLIN QUINN: Yes.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So
like speaking of social,
Hobbs talked about
social contract.
So we're now in this new phase
of social media contract.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
What does that look up?
What are we giving away and
what do we get in return now?
COLIN QUINN: Well, I mean, like
I say, it is, in some ways,
you expose so much stuff.
But at the same time,
nothing can really
get done, because everybody's
got a little bit of something.
How many times do you have
people pointing something out?
And then people, go, let's go
over your tweets in the past.
Everybody's like, whoa.
It's just everybody's
a little bit guilty.
So in a way, I guess, I'm not
sure where it goes from here.
But like nobody's pure.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Have
you changed your behavior,
like your social?
Like you started doing something
right when the internet came
out, and then all
of a sudden, you
go, oh, that's a big mistake.
I'm never going
to do that again.
COLIN QUINN: Well, no.
But my whole social media thing
was ironic from the beginning.
So it's kind of like this.
I'm just literally like a troll.
Even when I'm trying
to be on social media,
I'm always like even, you know?
I'm just like talking
about the weather.
Just my whole thing is
like about-- it's just
kind of ironically.
It was funny at the beginning.
I was telling you backstage.
When I first started Twitter
in like 2009 or whatever,
and I was like, Will Ferrell--
he had won this
Mark Twain Award--
and I was like, well, people
see him as a nice guy,
but when I worked at "SNL,"
it was quite the opposite.
He stole "Anchorman."
That was my script.
It was on my desk.
And then I came by later,
and he was putting it
in a copy machine.
And then I said, but
I don't blame him.
Heroin does that to people.
But then it became like a
real thing, where suddenly
"Huff Post" and
everybody was saying,
Colin Quinn says Will Ferrell
is a heroin addict, and a heroin
dealer.
I called him a dealer.
And then people are calling me.
And finally, it became like
I had to make a retraction.
But I've always been like just
obviously joking on Twitter.
I've never said a sincere
thing on Twitter in my life.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
That leaves me like--
in your show, you
talk about that we're
breaking up the country.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: It
needs to be, or it will be.
It doesn't matter.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So a
tweet like yours maybe
will be the Fort Sumter tweet,
that you may start something
that gets in the press.
COLIN QUINN: You mean
joking, and then it
becomes a real thing?
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
Right, right, right.
Like the mouse that roared.
COLIN QUINN: You're
right, though.
But you're right.
A tweet probably will
start our next war.
It will be a tweet, right?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yes.
So I don't know if you
anticipate something like that.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, my god.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So like
one thing that is on my mind
a lot is that it's relentless,
like the churn that we get
so much information, so much.
I remember a time where I could
go two weeks without knowing
what the president was doing.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
So do you disconnect?
I know it's part of
your work, but do you
find ways that you can
actually really disconnect
from that whole thing?
COLIN QUINN: I
mean, I haven't yet.
But I mean, because
it's just this thing.
You just a compul--
you have to go to your phone.
I never even.
I'm just like, nah.
And then when you have to
disconnect for an hour or two,
you feel great.
But then you're like, oh,
you catch up, and you feel--
like for the first
minute I'm catching up,
I'm like I'm so happy.
And then I just
get that sick thing
where like I've
seen this 100 times.
Everybody's saying
the same thing.
I'm saying the same.
Everybody's just the same.
But at first, I'm
just like, yeah,
it feels happy to come
back and say hello.
It's like meeting your friends.
When you meet a friend
for dinner today
that you used to be good
friends with, and you're like,
oh, I haven't seen
them in a long time.
And you remember the good times.
And then after minute, you're
like, ah, Jesus Christ.
Do you know what I mean?
It's the same old
feeling, you know?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: No offense to
all my friends, but you know.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So like
one concept in your show,
you talk about people not
listening, that we just talk.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Twitter
is a cacophony of shouting.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And so
like how do we fix that?
Have you seen that
ever in history
where it's just like people
had stopped listening,
and then they started?
Or there was some event that
brought us together more so.
COLIN QUINN: I mean, right.
I mean, obviously, like
after 9/11 in New York,
the month after 9/11 was
the weirdest New York.
No horns honking.
Nobody yelling at each other.
It was the strangest time,
where people were just--
and you're like, oh, people
can act nice if they want.
Everybody was nice
to each other.
It was a weird, weird time.
And then one day,
people started honking.
You just started
hearing horns honk.
You hadn't heard
them for a month.
It was crazy.
And then it was back to normal.
But I mean, my ideas would be--
like if I could be in charge
of society, what I would do
is I would once a year have
a Constitutional Convention,
and just have everybody.
Whoever you would
choose to speak.
But everybody in the country
also would have to agree.
Whatever gets said here,
you can't attack it.
You can't-- you have
to let it be spoken.
This is the safe space where
everybody says what they want.
You can't have
articles the next day.
It's not like a
popularity thing.
Just kind of everybody speaks.
You get what's considered
the best minds or whatever,
and just have everybody
speak honestly.
But you can't attack them.
Now, I don't know how
you'd pull that off.
But do you know what I mean?
Because part of it is
us, that we're like,
that person's the problem.
Do you know what I mean?
It's so easy to pick
one symbolic thing.
Do you know what I mean?
I talk about Trump.
I say after Trump
leaves, our problems--
the divide doesn't go away.
He's just a symbol of it.
But do you know what I mean?
So people are like, we've
got to get rid of Trump.
Yeah.
But once he leaves,
that still doesn't
change the inherent problems
that divide or whatever.
So that's just one problem.
So I'm just saying, instead
of it being just attacking
a person and thinking you could
crush that symbol by crushing
that person, it's
like I would like
it to be a more intelligent
conversation about what's
really--
where people could be
honest, and say what
they really feel, and just
try to figure this out.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
You've said before,
like Trump is just one part of--
like a symptom of that
disconnect that we have.
COLIN QUINN: Right, right.
He's just the symptom.
Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
But here in New York,
we've had plenty of people,
like different people,
and you talk about it in
your book and in your show,
about how we've gotten over it.
A new group will come in.
And after a rough time, it will
get integrated to then hate
the next group that comes.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
Oh, you mean-- yeah, when
I was growing up and stuff.
Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
So like is living in New York
that experience that people
need to actually to
be able to listen
or just to be able to coexist?
COLIN QUINN: No.
I mean, I feel
like New York is--
New York-- when I was growing
up, like I look back on it now.
I grew up.
It was very mixed; black,
white, Puerto Rican.
And we got along better.
I would say everybody
understood each other better
than they would say in
places where they wouldn't be
around each other all the time.
But people seemed to separate.
By the time I was
like 17, people
were going more away from each
other, towards their own group.
And it was just we
changed a lot ourselves.
Everybody did.
So I don't know.
I don't know what the--
I don't know.
You could have a racial
Constitutional Convention
and a red state, blue state
Constitutional Convention,
just a country of
conventions where people
are talking about the time.
But I mean-- yeah, I mean, I
would say that every time I
watch any show on TV, it just
deteriorates into people just
locking in, and just--
it's just strange that we're
still doing the same thing,
even though the results
are not going the way
that we would want them to go.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So
you have been raised
in so many parts of Brooklyn.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Like
Bensonhurst, Flatbush,
Park Slope.
How is it?
Do you go back and visit?
And like these places--
COLIN QUINN: Oh, no.
I'm one of those people.
I'm one of those cliche
New York people that
just sits there and
kicks myself, because we
used to work on the houses.
We would work on the
houses in Park Slope
when people would buy them.
I mean, my friends, they'd
bring in these kids,
like 15-year-olds.
We're 15.
We're doing the floors,
doing just all the prep work,
and all that.
And I'd be going,
look at these idiots
buying houses in Park
Slope, Sterling Place,
Sixth Avenue, Fifth Avenue.
I was like, these
people are psychotic.
I wanted to live
in Valley Stream.
That was my dream.
I said Valley
Stream, Long Island.
That's where I wanted to live,
because my cousins lived there,
and it was nice.
And I just had no idea.
And now I look, and I'm like--
I would've been a billionaire.
I would have been bigger than
Howard Schultz right now.
I'd be sitting and going, hey,
listen, I came from Brooklyn,
and now I'm a billionaire.
I'm going to be President
of the United States.
But I mean, it's crazy.
And Williamsburg, I
still wouldn't have--
I would never even.
It was like Williamsburg was
like gangs when I was a kid.
It was just like a
wild neighborhood.
Bushwick.
I mean, it was crazy.
So it's like I wouldn't have--
you know.
I look back on my
life, and I realize
it was-- basically
what I'm saying is
it was an unmitigated failure.
Instead of being
a comedian sitting
at a bar doing an
Irish accent, I
should have been a
real estate mogul.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: How
did you get into comedy?
COLIN QUINN: I was bartending.
I was a bartender
and a waiter at all
these different restaurants.
And I was like, I
wanted to be an actor
in the back of my
head, but I didn't know
how to go about being an actor.
It was like I was just
a haphazard person.
And then, luckily--
this is the early '80s--
I started doing comedy.
And comedy was just
starting to boom.
But I didn't realize
that at the time.
So I started, and
I'd wait on line.
And every week on the line,
every week, almost every--
most weeks it was
me, Chris Rock,
Adam Sandler waiting on
these lines to get into it
like an open mic
and do five minutes.
And we all got to
know each other.
And so it was like
1984 probably.
And then we started to
pass at these clubs.
And everybody
started-- it was just
this little group of comedians.
It was so much
smaller than today.
In some ways, it was easier.
I mean, there were
a lot of comedians
around that didn't make it, but
it was just such a small world
compared to today.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
Did your parents--
were they big fans of this?
Did they support
you through that?
COLIN QUINN: Oh, I
mean, I was already
like in early 20's by then.
I wasn't even living at home.
So it was like--
they weren't living
with each other anyway.
So it was like--
yeah, they were glad
I was doing something.
They were just like, yeah,
that's great, you know?
Nobody thought about comedy.
It was just like comedy
was like a crazy thing.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
COLIN QUINN: Like in those days.
Like, eh, this guy's a comedian.
People were just--
it was so much easier
to be a comedian in those
days, because you would just
go on a stage, and people
would start getting excited.
There's somebody going to
be a comedian on stage,
like nobody ever saw
a comedian before.
Now people are
like, ah, my cousin
does that for seven years,
and I tried it for two years.
It's not a big deal anymore.
But back then, everybody
was like, woo, comedian.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: OK.
So you lived in Park Slope for--
COLIN QUINN: For
most of my childhood.
I grew up in Flatbush, then
Park Slope, then Bensonhurst.
I lived with my girlfriend then.
Astoria, Queens.
Then I lived in Staten Island
for a brief period of time.
I don't talk about that.
No, I'm kidding.
And then I lived in Manhattan.
I lived in like
Yorkville, like East 78th
between First and York.
Then I lived on 45th
between 9th and 10th.
But in those days,
this was in the '80s,
those apartments were so cheap.
I won't even say it, because
everybody will kill me.
But it was like really--
I lived on East 10th between
A and B, like $400 a month.
It was almost like
a whole floor.
It was crazy, because they were
considered bad neighborhoods
back then.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
I read your book.
It's like it's funny, and it's
also a lot of autobiographical.
I don't think I've ever read
a book where the person gets
punched so much.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Like
all over, every chapter,
you get beat up.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
Well, like I said, I was a very
what they call beer muscles.
I was a very tough guy in here.
So I would go to
bars, and I always
wanted to be 6' 8", like
240, like my whole life.
Even when I was a little
kid, I resented the fact
that like I'd see
Connie Hawkins, who
was my childhood idol.
He was a basketball player.
And I was like, how come he's
6' 8", and I'm not 6' 8"?
So my whole life, I was--
so when I would get drunk,
I'd be like look
at that bouncer.
How come he gets to be 6'
5", and I'm-- you know.
So I'd just flick my
cigarettes at them.
And then they beat--
they'd beat me out, literally.
I didn't just get punched a lot.
I got punched out
into the street,
like the old school
beatings where
you'd go flying out of the club,
because I'd go after hours.
There's a lot of after
hours clubs in New York.
So I was a bartender all night,
so I'd go drinking after hours.
So it would be like 6:00 in the
morning, 7:00 in the morning.
I'm walking out of the bar,
like my shirt's all ripped,
all bloody, walking home.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Wow.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Well,
actually, it ends up
being part of your philosophy.
You talk about--
I think a friend
of yours, Harry,
mentioned there's a never
punched in the face club.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, right, right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: There
are two types of people;
those who have been
punched in the face,
and those who haven't.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
My friend came up with that one.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
That people that
have a certain amount
of respect for each other.
COLIN QUINN: Right, right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: That
others that haven't.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
They would just say--
well, that's another
thing from social media.
People talk a lot, those
digital soldiers, whatever,
computer guy.
And so people can just
say a lot of nasty stuff.
It's like this stuff is
going to lead to war.
That's why I worry
sometimes, because I'm like,
you can't just keep
talking to people,
ridiculing, attacking people.
People are going
to react one day.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just not human
nature to just think
people are just going
to take your abuse.
It's just the way it goes.
It's been proven in
every society, including
ours, many times.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
But maybe part of that
is that people haven't been
either punched in the face--
I'm sure we can fix that--
or that people haven't
been punched in the wallet.
COLIN QUINN: Right.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Inequality
is one of the things
that people talk about greatly.
COLIN QUINN: Sure.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Like
with people driving up
with Lamborghinis.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, right, like
lecturing some sheet metal
worker from the red
states and stuff.
Yeah, oh, yeah.
I mean, it's real stuff.
It's like people just
talking, and spraying people.
A lot of people in the
media or in showbiz,
whatever, just telling people,
look, this is how you have to--
the problem to me is like,
everybody, the whole country
is built on the fact that you
get to decide for yourself how
to think.
That's the only thing that
everybody kind of says, well,
that's one thing we came up.
And now everybody's just
trying to force everybody
to think the way they think.
And it's not working.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
You grew up.
Your parents were teachers.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And so
how did that shape you?
What type of teachers?
COLIN QUINN: I mean, because
they were-- my parents were--
my mother was just--
well, I almost said
just a housewife.
My mother was only
became a teacher
after my parents got divorced.
She went to college.
She didn't go to
college before that.
So she did it later in life,
and she taught special ed.
My father taught English.
And so she was a special ed
teacher all over Brooklyn.
And so yeah, it just
taught me to like reading.
So I loved to read
from early age.
That was my other
part of my thing
with my jacket and
my Irish thing.
I always had a book.
I usually had like a play.
Like I said, I was
going to be an actor.
So I always had
like a little play
tucked in my pants pocket
or my jacket pocket.
And then I'd be at the--
did you ever see like
a pompous asshole
at the bar who breaks out a play
and starts reading by himself?
That was me.
Strindberg, I'd be like, yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So
did you get any plays?
Did you do that?
COLIN QUINN: Did I
get into any plays?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: I got in two plays.
And one was just this weird--
I mean, I can't
even tell you what
they were about to this day.
But they were like these
weird experimental plays
in the East Village
in the early '80s,
where one was just some
lady who was pretending
to swim the whole time.
And then I had to carry--
but I had to carry her around,
like I was like the swim.
I mean, I was in
pretty good shape
when I think about it, carrying
somebody around a whole play,
you know?
I mean, I was like 23.
Even at the end of
the play, I was like,
Jesus Christ, this
is really hard.
And then I was in some other
play where it was just like--
I can't even remember
what it was about.
It was just insane.
But I was the worst.
I was the worst employee.
When I was drinking, all
I would be thinking about
was, yeah, just
sitting there smoking,
plotting how to get more drinks.
So I didn't even
care about anything
I was doing other than that.
Even when I bartended
I'd be like trying
to get back to my drinks.
So I was really a
compulsive personality.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
So how did you
get to "Remote Control,"
which I remember.
It was super fun.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was doing stand-up.
I had quit drinking.
So that's why I did
stand-up, because I was like,
I have nothing to lose.
That was the only
thing I really liked.
I had nothing to lose, so
it was like they took away
my best friend.
So I started doing
stand-up, because I
was like, I don't care if
I bomb in front of people.
That's nothing compared to this.
And so I was doing stand-up
for like three years.
And then they just
saw me at a club.
And then they hired me
because of my voice.
And my voice was
even more like this,
because I smoked
three packs a day.
So I talked like this.
Even though I was like
28, I talked like this.
So they thought it was funny.
I thought they were hiring
me for my brilliant comedy.
It was a disconnect.
So I thought, oh, they get
that I'm a great comic.
They were just like
making fun of the fact
that my voice was so stupid.
So the first week we had a big
fight, me and the MTV bosses,
where it was like,
I quit this show.
Do you know what I mean?
Because I was like, I'm not
doing commercials for you.
I just had this whole idea.
I'm like, well, I've got
to do the advertisements.
So I ended up I was so
resentful that I ended up
doing the advertising
like really sarcastically
for their products, to where
the people that advertised,
Casio or Mitsubishi,
like they're like,
this guy's disrespectful.
Either he starts doing our
advertisements sincerely
or he's out.
And I'm like, I'm
not doing shit.
But the show was on the air.
So all the kids that
were watching the show
loved it, because I
guess, they were like,
oh, this guy's insulting the
products while he's doing it.
So then they wanted to keep me.
So I lucked out that I was so
snotty that kids were like, ah,
ha-ha, like they liked it.
And then suddenly
advertisers were like,
oh, yeah, do them his way.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: That's great.
And how did that-- how did
you get onto "SNL" from there?
COLIN QUINN: Well, then
after MTV was over,
I was right back to like--
I was really--
I mean, I had to move
back in with my mother.
She was living in Bay
Ridge at the time.
I had to move in with my mother.
And people would see
me on the block going,
weren't you just on TV?
And I was back.
I had no money, because MTV
didn't really pay that much.
And it was just a
combination of things.
I don't know.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Free snacks.
COLIN QUINN: I was literally
living with my mother
and my niece in this apartment.
And so then I end up getting a
writing job, "In Living Color."
So I moved to LA.
"In Living Color" was in
its last couple of years.
So they brought me on
to write for that show.
So that gave me
enough to live on.
And then "SNL" hired
me as a writer.
And then once I was on there,
I started doing stuff on there.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Was
it weird to take over
for Norm Macdonald?
Was it awkward?
COLIN QUINN: Ah, the weirdest.
Yeah, it was really awkward.
It was bad.
Like speaking of social
media, at that time,
social media was almost new.
People just barely--
I don't know if was
Myspace or whatever,
but it had just started.
And I was one of
the first people
that had to deal with the
fact that this new guy sucks.
You're fat, you fat neck.
I'm sick and tired of
seeing his stupid face.
And I was like, what that?
I was so mad, but
it was like I was
one of the first
people that had to deal
with like feedback
on that digital level
that people didn't like you.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So
all over the globe.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
And it was really interesting.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So do you
watch "Saturday Night Live"
now?
Do you think it's
changed drastically
from when you were there?
COLIN QUINN: No.
I mean, I watch it
once in a while.
But I mean, I'll watch
it like everybody else,
where it's online Tuesday
morning or something.
Do you know what I mean?
I'm like, oh, let's
see what this one is.
And it's the same.
I mean, it's the same
as when I was there.
I see it from the side of like--
I'm like, oh, that person.
I would just imagine how it was
trying to get that sketch on.
So when I'm watching, I'm
like, oh, I bet that--
and look at that person.
I could tell their
lines got cut.
They're just standing
there in the back,
like why do they have
me in this sketch?
So you know it
from like whatever.
Like anything else, you just
look at the different angles.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: I'm
going to change topics.
something that-- you have your
one year anniversary coming up.
COLIN QUINN: Oh,
my heart attack.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: That
happened on Valentine's Day.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: How
has that changed you?
COLIN QUINN: Don't worry.
My girlfriend noted
it at the time.
She goes, yeah, Valentine's
Day, interesting.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
People-- yeah,
that's pretty drastic to
get out of Valentine's Day.
COLIN QUINN: You don't have
to Carl Jung to figure out
that one.
And yeah, I just
had a heart attack.
I just came out of the gym.
And I was like, oh,
man, I pulled a muscle.
And I was like,
oh, shoot, I think
I'm having a heart attack.
And then the next thing you
know I'm in the ambulance.
And I was like losing air.
And I'm like I'm actually--
I said, I might die right
now, because I'm losing air,
and I couldn't breathe.
I'm like, it hurts.
A heart attack like
physically hurts.
I didn't think it hurt.
I thought you went numb.
You don't go numb.
It's like something pushing,
like my elbow in your heart.
I was like, ah.
And then I was like,
I could actually die.
It was so weird, because I
always thought I'd get a--
I thought it'd be like a doctor
would sit me down and go,
listen, you have two years.
Get your affairs in order.
Take care of business.
I'll put out all my
mission statements online.
Visit all my enemies.
Get forgiveness from
all by past things.
And then, but no, it was
like, sometimes it just ends.
You forget about
that part of dying.
Sometimes it's not a big
dramatic two year bad movie
of the week type thing.
It's just you just die.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
So did you change
anything in that last year?
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
I mean, I changed.
I mean, everyone was like,
did you change your diet?
But I'm like, look, they're
giving me medication,
like heavy medication.
It's disrespectful to
science and the advances
they've made if I then
take the medication,
and don't trust that
their medication works
by having to change my diet.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
COLIN QUINN: That's my theory.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: But
have you visited enemies?
COLIN QUINN: The enemies?
No, I haven't visited them yet.
Because it's-- but yeah, I do
think in terms of like, oh,
what would I do if I really
only had a finite amount of time
to live?
Do you know what I mean?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
COLIN QUINN: I
mean, I know I do.
I mean, I know I'm
going to die now.
Like before I kind of knew,
but you never really--
you don't know for sure
until you're actually dying.
And you're like, oh, no,
this is going to happen.
But it hasn't-- it doesn't have
like this big effect on you
that you want it to, where
you're like, hey, man,
everything's great.
Do you know what I mean?
I'm still annoyed by
every little thing.
Just sitting, driving
around, another train.
Everything's just the same.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
So as a comedian,
you've been doing
this for decades.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Has it
changed drastically now
with what you can do?
And does that change what you
do, or like you have a pass?
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
I mean, look, you can only
do what you think is funny.
Of course, everything changes.
Do you know what I mean?
Everything starts out for
the right reasons, I think.
People, like even
political correctness
started out for
the right reasons.
But eventually, it
becomes mob rule.
Everybody's like, you
feel good telling people.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, yeah, people
can't say this.
So it starts out
for a good reason,
and then it becomes twisted by
just the general idea of people
get-- everybody
just gets involved.
But I mean, comedy,
it has changed.
It has changed in the
sense that there's
a lot of things that don't
get discussed in comedy, just
because people are
like, that's off limits.
And that's stupid,
because it's comedy.
You're supposed to
discuss certain things
if you can make them funny.
That being said, so like a
lot of people would be like,
well, I want to say
what I want to say.
And like I find myself defending
the rights of comedians
to say things sometimes.
I'm like, I don't
even agree with that.
I don't even like
what you're saying.
But I've still got to defend
it on general principle,
just because I'm a comedian.
Do you know what I mean?
So you're sticking
with the idea,
even though I'm like, I've
got to defend your dumb joke?
I don't even find it funny.
It's shock humor.
I don't go for that.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Right.
COLIN QUINN: So it's a
weird time for everybody
with everything, I feel like.
And comedy is just one
of those other things.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
In your show, you do that.
You are very blunt
about different topics.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, yeah.
I've always-- like
I said, I just
feel like if you make it
funny, then people will
more likely go, that's funny.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Yeah.
I mean, like you do like a
celebrity roast of the states.
COLIN QUINN: Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So like each
one, you call out all of them.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And
give them something.
Were any of those hard to do?
Do you want to share
any of those right now?
COLIN QUINN: I'll
share them, but I
don't think they're hard to do.
I mean, I don't think
they're hard like--
the New York story was
more like people are like,
you're talking about
everybody's ethnicity,
but people liked it, because
everybody thought-- you know.
Obviously, he's not
trying to attack.
I'm not trying to slip
anything by anybody.
I feel like that's a
big problem in comedy.
If you're trying to be
slick and say something
without taking ownership
of it, then you're
going to be in trouble.
But my state ones is like,
well, I say New York--
I just talk about the
fall of every state.
New York was once the
home of drunken writers
at the Algonquin roundtable.
And now it's drunken
texters at SantaCon.
And then Massachusetts, where
once Sam Adams pouring tea
into Boston Harbor, now it's
Fenway fans pouring Sam Adams
onto Yankee outfielder heads.
And just I go over all the--
just mocking every
state as you go along.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: It's great.
It was funny, very funny.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks, yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And before
I ask my last question,
we have two microphones.
So if you want to
ask something, feel--
COLIN QUINN: Wait.
What about you?
What about your-- I'm sorry.
What about your state Virginia?
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Virginia.
COLIN QUINN: I go Virginia,
the snobs of the south.
Stop trying to be
Connecticut, you hayseeds.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: That's good.
No, that's funny.
COLIN QUINN: You
think that's funny.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So again,
we're going to have questions.
So feel free to line up if
you have questions for Colin.
The last one.
You've hosted a comics
talk show, "Tough Crowd."
COLIN QUINN: Oh, yeah.
DAVID WINDMUELLER:
That was awesome.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Very tough.
You helped our troops
with your USO tour.
COLIN QUINN: Oh, yeah,
we did a USO tour.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: So nice.
And you have your
now an online--
you've had online
shows, "Cop Show."
COLIN QUINN: "Cop
Show," it's my baby.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: And
so, like what's next?
More directing, writing?
What's going on?
COLIN QUINN: I would like
to do more cop shows,
now that you mentioned it.
That's really my-- do
you know what I mean?
In fact, now that I'm here at
Google, I might as well say,
the problem with "Cop Show"
is that you didn't watch it.
And you guys know
how to get it out.
It's got like 100,000
views per show.
You need 8 million.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Mm-hmm.
COLIN QUINN: It's
too late anyway.
But go watch it.
It's funny.
I was going to say--
I was going to pull
a strategy move,
and I was like,
I'm over my head.
I don't know what
I'm talking about.
So everybody just watch it.
It is funny, though.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: It is funny.
COLIN QUINN: It's funny, right?
I swear to god, it's funny.
If you don't like it and
you see me in the street,
you punch me in the face.
Obviously, it's my go-to move,
getting punched in the face.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: All right.
We'll go to the questions.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
I watched "A New York
Story" a few years ago,
and I thought it was great.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I went to the
Minetta Lane Theater.
But my question for you is--
you touched on
this a little bit.
But there is a
lot of controversy
around what some
comedians talk about,
like certain topics
having to be off limits,
like racial jokes or sexuality
jokes, and things like that.
And I struggle with
that personally,
because some of the jokes,
I do find funny, personally.
So I have that struggle myself.
I'm like, oh, shoot, like
I don't want to laugh,
but it's making me laugh.
What is your
perspective on that?
Should some of these
jokes be off limits?
And that internal struggle
that some people may have,
like is it warranted?
Should we move past it?
Because I don't necessarily
think that everyone's bigoted,
but I understand the rationale
for not having these jokes.
So it's sort of a struggle
for me, personally.
COLIN QUINN: Yeah.
Well, that's-- yeah, I
mean, it's a good question,
because everybody gets
offended by something.
I always quote this
guy Jack Simmons,
who was a comedian from
the '80s, where I'm from,
the place where I came from.
But he used to
always go onstage,
and when people would moan,
he would go, come on, folks.
It's comedy.
Somebody has got to get hurt.
And that's the thing.
So we've just shifted
what's offensive now.
So it's kind of like, there
are things that offend me.
There are things
that offend you.
And like I say in
the show, I say,
since they've gotten
rid of ethnic humor
from mainstream society, because
they felt it encourages racism,
I go, that's proven.
Racism is gone.
So it was a great success.
Do you know what I mean?
I feel like there's too much
focus on stand-up material.
Everything is--
stand-up is not nice.
And sometimes people
say things that
make me mad in
stand-up, all the time.
But like you say, if you're
laughing, you shouldn't feel,
ugh, why am I laughing at this?
Like suddenly it makes
you into something that--
there's just a-- there's no--
what do they call it?
Suspension of disbelief, which
is a term that always bugged
me, because I think it supposed
to be a suspension of belief,
and suspension of disbelief.
But another time.
But anyway, the point is,
like when you're at a movie,
you say, OK, I'm
going into this world.
And stand-up, I know
it's not the same thing.
There is a lot more
truth to stand-up.
So it isn't all just jokes.
I get it.
But yeah, I don't feel--
I feel like it's
going down a path
that I can't imagine how there
will be jokes in five years,
because if everything falls
under this standard of,
you know what?
That group of people,
that's a little bit off.
I mean, you'll see it
now like in stand-up.
Somebody will say any
name of any group,
and people are like [GASPING].
Just before they
even get to the joke.
So it's like people say,
celebrate diversity.
Just don't point out
anybody is different.
Do you know what I mean?
Well, there's got
to be at some point,
someone's got to come with
a little clear point of what
it is.
It's just people marking down.
OK, that's an 8.5.
We're just going
to have to start
doing it based on, out of 10,
how offensive is that joke?
And how wrong am
I for enjoying it?
2.4.
Do you know what I mean?
Because stand-up gets to be in
this weird place where it will
be--
we might as well be in
the 1950s at a glee club,
where you're just like
everything's positive.
I mean, in stand-up,
everything's negative.
That's what it's about.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
But I don't-- personally,
I don't like it.
I'll say that.
I don't think it's
good for stand-up.
And I don't think--
I think most stand-ups agree
with me that it's weird.
And you don't want it to
become the kind of thing
where stand-up is just
motivational speaking,
or people are just lecturing the
audience, which happens a lot,
sometimes I feel like.
Where suddenly it was like,
now, this is what goes on.
And you're like, OK, we're
within the parameters.
Like, stand-up punches
down sometimes.
It doesn't just punch.
People are like, stand-up
shouldn't punch down.
Yeah, it should.
It punches up.
It punches down.
It elbows you in the
side of the face.
It's dirty.
Stand-up is wrong.
Do you know what I mean?
So that's the other
part of it that's
kind of getting
into a weird area.
I realize that I've spent the
last eight minutes answering
this question.
And don't think I'm not
aware that I've said nothing.
Such are the times we live in.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you speak in
your Northern Irish accent
for the next like--
until you're done?
COLIN QUINN: For
the next how long?
AUDIENCE: What?
COLIN QUINN: For how long?
AUDIENCE: Just until
we're done, I guess.
Or until someone
tells you, please
don't speak in an Irish accent,
because I don't understand you.
COLIN QUINN: (IRISH
ACCENT) Yes, I will.
I'll do it like that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
COLIN QUINN: (IRISH ACCENT) And
I'll tell you something else.
I hope Irish people
don't see it,
because they might
think it stinks.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'll give you the
out, and answer this however
you feel most comfortable.
So when you talk about the
evolution of stand-up comedy,
especially political
commentary, like thinking back
to Lenny Bruce, Bill Hicks,
where we are now, is it easier?
Is it harder?
Is it just the exact
same situation?
Are we in a different place?
Have audiences evolved?
Have comedians evolved?
Or are we just stuck on a loop?
COLIN QUINN: From
those days, you mean?
Yeah, I mean, this is going
to be another long-winded one.
I'm just warning
you ahead of time.
I can sense I'm going
to be rambling again.
But it's evolved.
Here's how you know it's
going to be too long.
It's evolved and devolved
at the same time.
I really am a big mouth.
But it's evolved
in that people--
like when I was doing
comedy in the '80s,
people would just get away
with murder, just cheap things.
You'd be like, that's
not even funny.
It's just the shock or
whatever of the audience.
So now people are listening
more, which is good.
But it's devolved in the
sense that everybody--
I feel like there's
almost like a film,
like a fake film
over everything.
So when people speak,
it's almost like we
all agree like, OK,
you're saying this exists
that we know doesn't exist.
And then the jokes will
come within this fake world
we've created.
It wasn't as long
as the other one.
But it was just as
hard to figure out.
I don't even know
what I'm saying.
But do you know what I mean?
I just feel like there's
something very fake going on,
and it's infected
stand-up, too, you know?
Where people are like,
it should be appropriate.
Stand-up should be appropriate.
It's like, no, the
whole point of stand-up
is it's not appropriate.
It's kind of--
I mean, part of the
fun of a stand-up show
is you're like, oh, my god.
Come on, man.
That's too much.
Do you know what I mean?
And now it's sort of
like that too much
is based on something fake.
So people are almost
forcing themselves.
I'm single-handedly bringing
down the stand-up industry
right now.
You're going to go, I don't
want to go to a comedy club
if it sucks as bad as he says.
But I'm saying there's still
a lot of great stand-up
out there.
Hey, there's still a
lot of great stand-up.
But I mean, there's something.
When it comes to
politics or whatever,
there's just a general
feeling of appropriate that's
not what stand-up is to me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: All right.
Well, thank you, Colin Quinn.
"Red State Blue State."
COLIN QUINN: Thanks.
DAVID WINDMUELLER: Playing until
March 16 at the Minetta Lane
Theater.
And we thank you
very much for coming.
COLIN QUINN: Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.